[Music]
we're going to begin with the deepening
crisis in afghanistan the u.s president
is threatening to strike back in
response to attacks outside kabul
airport as many as 60 people including
13 members of the american military have
been killed the armed group isil has
claimed responsibility joe biden says
the service members who died are heroes
and he's vowing to make those
responsible pay the president has asked
military commanders to draw plans to
strike back the taliban has condemned
the attacks the group's spokesman told
al jazeera the area in which the assault
happened is under the responsibility of
the foreign forces
there is this attack but then there's
also the situation around the airport
the gatherings of tens of thousands of
people around kabul airport is a
suitable location for these attackers
this is in fact the security mishandling
a big error from their part and a big
mistake we've warned the foreign forces
several times of the repercussions of
large gathering around the airport
mohammed qazi international airport is
where thousands of people have been
gathering desperately hoping to flee
afghanistan western countries have been
using the airport to evacuate their
citizens their troops and afghan allies
charles stratford begins our coverage
ambulances rush through the streets to
collect the wounded bodies are lifted
onto stretchers
the two attacks by suicide bombers
happened close to the abbey gate
entrance of kabul airport near the baron
hotel
there was a sudden explosion we climbed
out and saw that there were many people
affected people were hurled everywhere
their brains were scattered there were
also foreign forces who were fallen
i saw at least four or 500 people there
the explosion was really powerful half
were hurled into the water others on the
ground outside we carried the wounded
here on stretchers and here my clothes
are completely bloodied
the barren hotel is controlled by the uk
and nato forces it is one of the places
where tens of thousands of afghans have
been gathering after the taliban took
control of kabul on august the 15th
they've been going there to have their
papers processed before being evacuated
out of the country
western governments and security experts
in kabul had been warning about
potential attacks around the airport for
days
the taliban told al jazeera it had
intelligence about potential car bombs
in the area and also warned people to
stay away
an increasing number of nato countries
have already announced a halt to their
evacuation operations
and these attacks jeopardize remaining
flights
meaning many afghans who want to leave
their country
and may have all the necessary documents
to do so could be left behind
well let's speak to charles stratford
who's in kabul for us charles it's only
a matter of days before all the foreign
troops are out of afghanistan and
security for afghanistan falls to the
responsibility of the taliban are there
any indications how the taliban is
planning to beef up security in the
country
well the taliban has so far we know that
they have been pulling in fighters from
the provinces to try and better protect
kabul and they've been doing that for
the last
few days
but as the attacks yesterday proved um
seemingly too little effect
um although the taliban blamed the
americans uh for causing the hysteria um
and and causing
pushing the amount of people in that
direction to try and get out of the
airport because of what they're offering
an evacuation out of the country it's
got to be said that the taliban are
actually supposed to be in control of
the area outside the perimeter fence of
the airport and yesterday as we were
beginning to hear these increasing
warnings of an imminent attack
the situation in that area was
incredibly tense the taliban
more aggressive
arguably than we've seen them uh before
trying to keep people out of that area
they'd uh put up an additional barrier a
couple of buses across the uh the abbey
road entrance into the airport uh that's
the southern gate and that's where one
of these attacks uh happened the other
one close by at the baron hotel
we know according to the pentagon that
uh the americans and the taliban have
been working together in in trying to
protect um the civilians and the airport
from attacks and it's very interesting
that last night
um we heard
fighter jets or at least one fighter jet
above
and it was about 10-15 minutes later as
this jet was still in the area um that
there was an almighty explosion and
everybody thought goodness you know it's
going it's another horrific attack
um it transpires that it wasn't
according to the taliban it was the
americans
blowing up
infrastructure or possibly ammunition
it's difficult to say
before they
obviously withdraw but
although we're seeing at this stage and
so the pentagon say cooperation between
the two sides
that in theory all ends in a couple of
days and it is obviously
debatable
as to how competent the taliban are
going to be in dealing with this isil
threat
that's going to be the key question
isn't it because we know that isil has
at least claimed responsibility for the
for this attack one would imagine that
the taliban given the fact that in as
you say in a couple of days time they
are going to be solely responsible for
security in afghanistan they're going to
have to be rethinking what the perceived
threat is from iceland afghanistan
i think yesterday was
a horrific tragic rude awakening just
how big a threat isil are
just to put a little bit of context on
this as the taliban moved towards kabul
over the last few weeks they have been
freeing
opening up prisons on their way to the
capital to free taliban fighters but in
and amongst those fighters staying in
the same prisons being held there were
what some report to be possibly
thousands of isil fighters that have
been captured in recent years they of
course now are free
and there are
more weapons available arguably in this
country now that the americans have gone
and left so much behind certainly in
some areas according to our sources
so that of course poses a huge threat
and as we're
saying
what the taliban are probably not going
to get or certainly don't have is the
kind of intelligence gathering
that the americans have offered the
previous government
obviously the kind of air power and
target
the ability to be able to make precise
strikes against isil
in this country so
arguably the taliban that their backs
are
seemingly this stage um against the wall
um and um
it's it's very difficult at this stage
to see you know how they can cope
although one thing
most analysts will tell you is that um
no matter there being questions over
their ability to be able to run a
country with respect to the country's
finances for example
and this country faces huge great
financial and economic problems one
thing analysts say is well the taliban
can deal with security well they're not
going to have birds in the sky they're
not going to have fighter jets and as i
say there are a lot of isil freed isil
prisoners out there now according to the
people that we've spoken to
charles stratford and kabul charles
thank you
well kimberly hockett has more from the
white house on u.s president joe biden's
response to the attacks
i bear responsibility for
fundamentally all that's happened
commander in chief of the u.s military
joe biden holding a moment of silence
for the americans killed in thursday's
bombings in kabul the deadliest day for
the u.s military in more than a decade
but despite the deaths biden says the
evacuation and the withdrawal will
continue until august 31st
we will not be deterred by terrorists
we will not let them stop our mission we
will continue the evacuation
this despite at least 13 u.s service
members killed on thursday and at least
18 more injured dozens of afghan
civilians have also been killed or hurt
by the blasts outside the kabul airport
at its abbey gate and the nearby barren
hotel the u.s is blaming the group isil
k a rival of the taliban for the attacks
we thought this would happen sooner or
later it's tragic that it happened today
the u.s says its mission to evacuate all
those wishing to leave afghanistan will
not change the president says the united
states will retaliate against those
responsible for thursday's blasts
we will not forgive
we will not forget
we will hunt you down and make you pay
but some republican members of congress
are outraged and are calling for biden's
resignation they're furious by reports
u.s officials allegedly gave the taliban
the names of americans and afghan allies
permitted to enter kabul's airport
perimeter the move was designed to speed
up the evacuation but critics accuse
officials of generating a kill list for
america's enemies
former navy seal republican congressman
dan crenshaw wrote on twitter if true
this qualifies as borderline treason we
need to find out who's responsible for
giving the taliban a hit list and they
need to go to prison
biden's not denying such a list may
exist but also did not confirm some
republicans and democrats argue the
taliban cannot be trusted with america's
security they blame biden for the crisis
but biden insists well the taliban is
not america's friend it's in their
self-interest
that
we leave when we said
once u.s troops have withdrawn president
biden says that the united states will
still have the ability to evacuate
anyone left behind
but his orders remain unchanged the
military will depart on august 31st
kimberly hellcat al jazeera the white
house
pj crowley is a former u.s assistant
secretary of state for public affairs
and former u.s national security council
spokesman he says isil k is fighting for
resources and territory
the islamic state is going to claim this
as a great victory the taliban is
pointing a finger at the united states
saying if the occupation forces were not
there this would not happen
the united states is going to withdraw
from afghanistan in the coming days and
we'll have to find you know another way
maybe in concert with the taliban
of striking the islamic state forces who
are responsible this attack and trying
to over time you know to minimize the
impact they can have in afghanistan
and elsewhere in the region i think what
they want is power influence and money
you know they're situated close to the
afghan drug trade
and that obviously is very very
profitable
uh in terms of of drugs uh moving
outside of afghanistan
you know and ideology is a part of this
um you know they have a stricter
stricter coda than even al qaeda and the
taliban
um
so on the one hand they have a mix of
motives on the other hand they only
number a couple of thousand you know and
and as we've seen you know across
conflict in afghanistan over the years
there's always been you know movement of
people you know with this allegiance and
coalition one time this allegiance and
coalition
another time so i think this will be a
major test you know for the taliban
you know can they shift gears from
running a successful insurgency to
running a government and actually
controlling territory